THIS WILL BE THE TIME ARE COMIN
GOT THROUGH.ON,  BUT IF YOU LOO
ROSTER, YES RST PERIOD.
NOT A LOT OF SHOTS GETTING
THROUGH FOR EITHER TEAM.
ANOTHER LOOSE
>> PICKED UP BY
WELL, WILLYFULLY YOU
GOT ALL THAT.
McCARRON WILL SERVE THE FIVE-
MINUTE MAJOR.POWERPLAY NOW FOR
COYOTES.ON THE BENCH.
>> Willy: GOSTISBEHERE LOST TH
BY NOVAK.
PENALTY CALL  KELLER IS 5 AND 4
GO.
McCARRON
>> Willy: OFF TO JOHANSEN AND O
IT IS A 2-0THAT MUCH.
THAT WAS BLOCKED BY FABBRO.WILL
4 AND 4. GLOVE SAVE,
SAROS.THE
BUMPER.
NASHVILLE ROTATING AROUND.
NO SET POSITIONS.
JOHANSEN CROSS IC THE PENALTY
>> Willy: IS IS JUST THEY
THE GUYS CONTINUE TO PROTECT
THE MI
HOW ABOUT THAT FOR JEANNOT THE
PREDS' BENCH.
SAROS WILL TAKE IT BEHIND THE
WHAT Y